So
A couple things I want to tell you about today
Many things I want to tell you about
I want to tell you
Uhm
I want to give you a schema that is going to enable you to understand
I think it will enable you to understand stories
Like the one I told you last time, you remember Jonah and the whale
I want to provide you with the schema so you can understand stories like that
But many many more stories like that
Partly what I am telling you about today
In some sense are archetypes
And an archetype, it is an idea that was made most popular over the last 100 years by Carl Jung
But it's a much older idea than that
It's really a platonic idea in some ways
And it means something like fundamental pattern
And so an archetype manifests itself in different ways
It could be a pattern of emotional response
Like it can be something you are feeling
It could be the way that emotional response displays itself
On your body, on your face
It could be the way that emotion feels and displays itself on your face
And plays itself out as a drama in your local environment
So like an angry argument is an archetypical phenomenon
And the reason it's archetypical is because
Well, you have them, you have them, you have them, you have them, everyone has them
and so you can't  really think about them as individual, you have to think about them as universal
and you can't think as about something that you created in a sense
although, in a sense you do
but it's also as something that happens to you
now, when you read about Jung and archetype is quite confusing because you can never be sure
whether it's talking about an instinct, an emotion, a motivational system, or a sub-personality
or a sub-personality in which these things manifest itself, or even the social drama that's being played out
in time and space in the social world
but a real archetype I would say is all of those things at the same time.
Now, we use archetypal means of expression to represent how we act
And that's not the same thing as we think representing what the world is made out of
It's a very different thing, so you could say in some sense we tell stories and understand stories
so that we can figure out how people act and how they should act
and then we conduct science so that we can figure out what the world's like
from a material objective perspective and
the two things coexist uneasily
I think the more primary form of knowledge is actually how to act with a scientific model nested inside
because the most important question you have to solve as a living organism isn't what the world is made out of
it's how you should act in the world
say from a darwinian perspective even
so that you can live long enough to reproduce.
that's basicly from a strict biological perspective
in some sense that's what you have to do in order to be successful
it's kind of obvious
first of all 'cause you are not very successful if you just go and die
and then, of course, death from a genetic perspective and failing to leave offspring are much the same thing
Now, one of the questions might be
how is that we conceive of the world as a place to act in
and that's partly I'm gonna tell on the hypothesis for you and then explain the significance of that hypothesis
and the hypothesis involves the description of what you might consider consitituent elements
and also transformation processes
as far as I can tell, the constituent elements of the stories that we tell
about how the people act and should act are characters
Now that makes sense, right, because  you really can't have a drama or story without characters
Now, the thing is that characters have to be understandable
and so, for them to be understandable they sort of have to be like you
or they have to be like someone you know, but they have to be human
but than again it's not exactly that they're human, because
even when you're telling a story about what happened to you today
it's interesting to think about what you do
so someone might say "well, how is your day?", and you say "fine"
i mean, maybe it's the lowest level, lowest resolution highest abstract srory
"my day was fine"
It's pretty boring story, it's better then terrible, I suppose
it's not interesting, it's not detailed
but person gets the notion that things went according to plan
or, more specificly, that things unfolded the way you wanted them to